J'ai été conçu pour sauver le monde d'
accord qu'est-ce que nous regardons c'est la
bande-annonce est une admiration je suis désolé
nous allons regarder vers le ciel Oh
avion nous avons un avion tout le monde
et voir oh oh je vais prendre ça du premier
espoir c'est  juste une phase se produit ange sur
un chemin vers la paix
il y a l'extinction ce sont mon genre
de personnes qui essaient de créer une armure à
travers le monde mais j'ai créé quelque chose de
terrible l'intelligence artificielle est-ce
pourquoi nous nous battons pour que nous puissions mettre fin au combat et
rentrer à la maison  bien étonnamment échoue j'aime que
nous parlions qui semble en sécurité ici nous
sommes tous
avec rien d'autre que notre esprit et notre volonté de
sauver le monde c'est le plus grand
discours de tous les temps je reprends toujours après
vous les garçons Atta fille nous pouvons les déchirer
à part
ces petits bras de l'ensemble j'ai fait de mon
mieux
tu es si intelligent pourquoi ne réponds-tu pas c'est de
cela que je parle regardons-le
à nouveau si nerveux mes nerfs sont
tirés sur toi oups
il l'a encore fait